elon musk has become the world's richest
person with a fortune of 189.7 billion
dollars
shares of musk's electric vehicle maker
tesla rose by nearly eight percent as of
12 30 p.m
eastern time on friday pushing musk's
net worth up by over 11 billion dollars
in past
amazon's jeff bezos despite a report
from bloomberg earlier this week
claiming that musk became the world's
richest person on wednesday
by forbes calculations the tesla chief
didn't officially take the number one
spot until friday morning the tesla
ceo's wealth has grown at an
unprecedented rate over the past few
months
musk has added 165 billion dollars to
his fortune since march 2020 when he was
worth 24.6 billion dollars
much of that increase is thanks to
tesla's skyrocketing share price which
rose more than 720
in 2020. in the first week of 2021 it
gained another 20
musk initially overtook facebook ceo
mark zuckerberg to become the world's
fourth richest person in early november
he then surpassed microsoft co-founder
bill gates for the number three spot
a month later musk leapfrogged french
luxury tycoon bernard arno
to become the world's second richest
person
[Music]